ciao nascosa è stata da parte di una mia
amica dieci anni fa inventava la scusa
che lei non aveva posto in macchina
perché i posti erano occupati dai
peluche che dire niente beh era fermo da
mesi ma chi guida ciao ragazzi
bentornati a una nuova puntata di vita
buttata mi siete mancati tantissimo non
vedevo l'ora di riprendere volevo fare
un sacco di cambiamenti volevo cambiare
tipo che ne sono gli studi avere che ne
so le cose carine dietro era dietro caso
si vede che se questo è invece la fine
ho deciso di rimanere negli studios di
casa mia e quindi è sempre la solita
merda comunque per chi non lo sapesse
vita buttata una specie di raccoglitore
in cui in cui nel quale raccoglie vita
buttata per chi non sapesse cazzo evita
buttata il tema di questa puntata è
scuse ignobili
e per riprendere questa seconda stagione
che realtà è uguale alla prima stagione
ho deciso di chiedere la vera star forse
di questa rubrica di dargli una mano e
di venire a farmi compagnia stiamo
parlando niente poco di meno che di mio
fratello enrico
sembra fatta di gioco copriamo questo
esempio se devi avere un esempio ma era
punta era una persona molto molto
possessiva una volta conobbi un ragazzo
m of the con questo ragazzo si che una
bella intesa
io volevo invitarlo a casa solo che melo
proibì categoricamente perché non voleva
che camminasse sul suo stesso pavimento
e non voleva che respirasse la stessa
aria che respiri e così lui e proprio
volano a una scusa assurda che ho
ricevuto io è stata quando un mio ex mi
ha lasciata dicendomi di avere il pene
troppo piccolo a meno è stato onesto
no io vorrei trovare un modo per
mettermi in contatto con lei
ragazzi io devo trovare un modo di
riuscire a chiamare queste stalking dopo
una persona massimo di può vedere sto
chiamando indice non rispondo quel pazzo
una volta mi hanno montato le domeniche
ac però chi tra direi con nichi mollo
che un modo per dire non mi piace
abbastanza aspetti andiamo a vederlo
sembra pure un bel ragazzo in realtà io
vidi sembra un'altra persona si
tradirebbe che il controllo sconosciuto
e pensa che quando sei ferito lemay ho
usato delle scuse ignobili in realtà io
non so scuse allora più o meno un
annetto fa eravamo in classe è una mia
compagna era stata chiamata per essere
interrogata ha tirato fuori la solita
scusa della nonna morta e va bene ha
fatto saltare a metà della seconda ora
entra solo anno in classe che mi
consegna il pranzo che aveva dimenticato
a casa le nonne in genere su due è vero
figurati se il professore avesse detto
guarda quella è la tua nonna avesse
allora mia madre alle tono aveva 34 35
anni chiaramente divorziata in una sera
poi torna a casa mentre io ero già letta
e poi la borsa a fianco cambia letto
aperta via si guarda dentro abiti
impaccati preservativi chiaramente
rimasi sconvolta volevo morire a trevi
dell'espressione fra mia faccia capire
qualcosa andasse vide il pack
preservativi e mi disse dio quali sono
di modica mia amica si è dimenticati
orale telefono dice questa telefonata ha
palesemente finta via mentre le parlava
le telefona i cieli sono alte che aveva
attaccato alla faccia voleva morire
lei il demonio esigenze di le mans e
buttare bisogno più bravi e più assurda
che mi abbiano mai detto non riesco ad
uscire perché non riesco ad allacciarmi
le scarpe e mia madre non è in casa però
lanciarne e non posso uscire con le
scarpe slacciate questo per me è un
genio questo è un appende di
rialzo fitto in piedi magari avevano sei
anni cha vogliamo volevo raccontarti la
mia esperienza
il fatto che un giorno stavo due mie
amiche e mio fratello erano usciti a un
certo punto non sapevo come andare via
si sono distratti un attimo e sono
scappata senza dire niente senza nessuna
scusa il giorno dopo mi hanno chiesto
nella motivazione o cambiamo discorso è
che gli dici no io una scusa ce l'avrei
cosa io avrei fatto così non posso
dirvelo la cosa più assurda che mi ero
mai croppi napoli che è stata quella che
da ex ragazzo ha utilizzato per
lasciarmi dopo un anno e mezzo di
relazione
non sapendo come altro fare
evidentemente aveva deciso di mettere in
scena una pièce teatrali in non
indifferente livello fingendosi
gravemente depresso per oltre due
settimane dilazionando sapientemente il
tempo tutti i sintomi della depressione
per non farmi sospettare troppo saranno
sempre un colorito emaciato e mia
presenza è nota ha perfino finto e di
venirmi tra le braccia per poi
semplicemente dirmi un bel giorno che la
causa di quella depressione ero io che
lo ha deciso di lasciarmi ragazzi le
persone non hanno le palle per parlare
ma poi si truccava per avere un colorito
che cazzo se ne frega se si truccavano
ma è questo il punto
era un modo di parlare per buttarti
dentro la situazione quindi il colorito
capace che era in realtà starà flashato
poi c'era la faccia la cura la scusa più
strana che abbiamo ricevuto è stata
quella del mio ex che mi ha lasciata
perché si sentiva in colpa nei confronti
tutti anche senso nei confronti di dio
magari perché avevano consumato vanno
consumati rapporti palesemente consumo
di rapporto c'era dio
[Risate]
ciao sun francescane capitatagli fatti
devono fare incrociato pubblicitario
dovevo riempire dei moduli pubblicitari
venderli allora c'era un cliente a cui
ho detto scrivile subito mai posta a
porta si scrive apposta per il povero
pazzo praticamente avevo fatto una festa
con i miei amici ho detto ci andiamo a
fare un giretto ci mangiamo una cosa
fuori io avevo invitato gli amici più
stretti somma le amiche più strette
una mia amica non arriva e il ritardo
finché ne ricevo la scusa scusa e le non
posso venire perché non posso e io sono
in modo ti rispondo stronza premio oscar
premio oscar ennio scarpa cinque anni fa
sto con questo ragazzo sta di fatto che
si inventa di aver perso la memoria così
da un giorno all'altro si conseguenza
gli scrive perché dalle contestazioni
che legge io sono la sua ragazza
vengo a scoprire che questa enorme
cazzata la dice a tutti tranne che i
suoi genitori
una sera siamo a cena con i suoi
genitori e gli tirò fuori questa storia
non ti dico la figura di merda che gli
ho fatto fare ciao complimentoni
grazie grazie mille grazie mille
innanzitutto ti stimo tantissimo ma ci
avrei fatto un'altra cosa
quindi non ti ricordi che aspettiamo un
bambino pellistri giocare i loro giochi
sei pazzo perfetto il mondo alle anatre
blu etico qua è così che loro messi
davanti alla loro follia devono per
forza tutto il giorno a scaramuccia
[Applauso]
nello scritto un messaggio ragazzi
tranquilli se volete che i vostri
messaggi non vengano riconosciuti basta
che mi scriviate camuffa la voce
eleggono bisogno di passare la trappa ha
preferito per le grand quale letto nella
sua bibbia
mi lascio perché aveva sonno e voleva
ma cosa nel senso per sempre ma semmai
svegliato stress che cambiò questo
pappagallo abbastanza grande e si sentì
mal dove ma portarlo in clinica e quindi
di saltare le ore di educazione fisica
tornare a scuola
la professoressa mi chiese perché non
era da fare educazione fisica
dell'ultima volta
e questo resta sono andato in clinica
apportare il mio uccello a farsi vedere
e la crisi amare perché credeva che io
fossi volgare e voleva mettermi una nota
sul registro se lo stato la rinascita
lavoro che del pappagallo e cioè non ci
credo che il tuo non essere state le
uniche foto il milan paga chi accoglie
solo volevo essere mutande niente dovevo
far vedere le mie foto in mutande che
pagano sulla spalla devono essere
ovviamente era perché lo avevo preso da
poco giocatore
ciao gu ago circa 9 anni e alimentari
durante una lezione il mio compagnetto
di banco forse preso dalla noia decide
di girarsi verso di me e tirarmi un
pugno sull'occhio
ovviamente io mi sono fatta malissimo la
sua scusa è stata che pensava che rima
di ricevere il tuo io avrei chiuso
l'occhio
io ho un'idea arriviamo alla fine di
questo video terminiamo lo ragazzi siamo
arrivati alla fine di questo video io vi
ringrazio per i messaggi che mandate
grazie mille a tutti grazie mille a
tutti
pachino con chiederlo a me ci penso io
ragazzi grazie per i vostri messaggi
alla fine volevo dire che la seguitemi
su instagram ci poteva che ci penso io
seguitemi giusti e tira
[Risate]